i have a friend and mentor who is known
as the master of
segways and so in this video i'm excited
to share
uh how he would change the topic of
conversation
because oftentimes you might be in a
and it's not you're not really feeling
it and you want to shift
topics and it could be at
a holiday with your family talking about
politics which you really would like to
avoid
or it could just be at work and you just
need to steer a discussion so that it's
a more productive meeting
in this video i'm going to share a funny
way from my mentor to
change the topic of conversation i'm
going to share a clever
way to change the topic of conversation
and i'm gonna share
an honest way to change the topic of
conversation
here we go
all right if this happens to be the
first time that we're meeting in
cyberspace i'm chad
and my partner and i wrote a book called
ask powerful questions create
conversations that matter
and so i while i have
i feel like i've learned about two
percent of what it takes to make
meaningful conversations happen to
navigate uh difficult
topics and while i have 98 to learn
i've got some stuff that i think would
be really useful for you and which is
why exactly why i've recorded this video
and so funny way funny way to change the
topic of conversation
came from a good friend and mentor
brenton who
i worked with at an organization called
world in conversation
and in the group what he would do
as a way of segwaying conversation he
had a formula
and it was you just insert speaking of
blank and you insert whatever the person
was speaking about
let's talk about blank whatever he
wanted to talk about so
speaking of politics
who's hungry right and so i ended up
being though and
there's no way that i can fully capture
the magic that he did it with it was
just
every single segway that he had was just
created a little bit of joy but somehow
it actually did work so even though it
was obviously
abrupt and a bit
crazy even in the way that he segued by
saying
speaking of whatever we're talking about
let's talk about
blank insert something completely
irrelevant that he's changing the topic
to
for some reason it worked and so i'd
invite you to actually try out that
formula
speaking of blank let's talk about blank
or insert whatever it is that you want
to talk about at the end so
speaking of is the key phrase to tuck
into
your back pocket because to change the
topic completely out of the blue
feels really jarring but when you
reference what's currently being talked
about
and then offer the new topic it doesn't
feel like such a
far leap or jump so that's the funny way
the clever way to change the topic of
conversation
is to follow your curiosity so
is exponential and we forget that
sometimes we think because we're talking
about
one particular sort of umbrella topic
that that's the only we're kind of stuck
in that lane
and yet in conversation no matter what
anybody's saying about
whatever topic you are learning tons of
different information
right so if you ask me hey chad what's
the story of the ring on your finger
i might tell you about how i met kate
and
that entire story and development now
in me telling you that you would
obviously learn the facts that i shared
with you
but you'd also learn something about how
i feel about kate based on the energy
that i'm talking with
you would learn a little bit about me
and my way of thinking from this even
though i'm not specifically talking
about that
and so the clever way to change the
topic of conversation is to
listen for what you're naturally curious
about
and ask a question rooted in that
curiosity
to guide the conversation that way
because there's plenty of data in the
room
to take a conversation in any direction
and so when i say conversations
exponential
let's say you learned somebody said was
talking for about a minute
let's say you learned five things each
of those five things
could be a separate question it could be
turned into a separate question
and a separate path of conversation and
so if you want to change the topic of
conversation
if three of the things that you learned
were about that topic
don't ask about those ask about the ones
that were brought up in the conversation
but don't necessarily
really relate now this is a bit of a
passive way to change the topic of
conversation
so you may be met with some resistance
from people saying
what do you mean like change like that's
not what we're talking about
and they might want to pull you back
into that current topic
and if that's the case if that happens
for me
the third and probably the best way to
change the topic of conversation
is the honest way and the honest way
to change the topic of conversation is
to
point out the elephant in the room and
acknowledge that whatever you're talking
about right now
is not working or is not productive or
is not what you'd like to talk about
or just state what it is or why it is
you'd like to change the topic of
conversation and then
do it so state what you'd like
state why you would like to shift the
conversation by noticing the dynamic
that's currently present in the room
and then say let's talk about blank now
depending on the group depending on the
context you may want to
seek permission so to say hey i feel
like we've
are talking about this a little bit in
circles we only have 30 minutes with
each other
can we table this right now
and talk about blank instead can we
table the discussion about the game last
night
and talk about what we have to get done
so that we can end our meeting on time
do you see how in that i point out the
elephant in the room i took a
break from the the content of the
conversation
and i pointed out and accessed the
process of the conversation
and then i invited the group or the
person
to come with me on that journey so in
order to
really and deeply change the topic of
conversation
you've got to point out what's currently
happening and why that might not be
working for you
let me give you one add-on tip
to the honest way to change a
conversation and that is
sometimes if you for whatever reason you
don't feel comfortable pointing out the
dynamic pointing out the elephant in the
room or
saying you don't want to talk about
whatever is currently being discussed
you can state your intention really
clearly for
why and what you want to change the
topic to so for example let's say we
were talking about lions
but we wanted to talk i wanted to talk
about zebras
so i'm using a generic example so that
you can
insert your own dilemma here so if
you're watching this video because you
really want to figure out how to change
the topic from
politics to what people are going to do
next week
right you can fill in that blank so if
we're talking about lions and i want to
talk about
zebras i could say hey i think we've
talked about lions enough
i'm kind of done can we move on and chat
about zebras
or you could leave the lions out of it
and you could just say if you're in the
middle of talking about lions you could
just say
hey i would love right now to shift the
conversation a little bit
and talk about zebras instead is
everybody okay with that
stating that intention might be enough
now if you've got a particularly
rebellious or resistant group or a group
that really likes lions and they don't
want to let go of the lions
what you might do is state your
intention to talk about zebras
really clearly framed a as a value
to the group so to say something like
hey we've got limited amount of time and
i would love to connect more with all of
you so can we talk about zebras
instead can we make that shift so you
see you're kind of framing the benefit
of saying hey i think this would be
actually more useful more productive to
chat about this
now in any of these strategies that i
shared is it possible
that somebody just says no i'm talking
about lions i'm going to continue to
talk about lions you can't do anything
about it
i'm going to talk about lions yes that
is possible and yet
unlikely because we have a desire
to fit in and belong and so
if there's enough of a kind of even
nonverbal consensus in the group of like
yes please change the topic from lions
to zebras i'm so done with this um it's
unlikely that somebody
is gonna stand alone and fight that for
too long before saying okay fine
and and to go along with everything
doesn't always happen
your scenario is going to be specific
to you and there's no way that i can
know that or could know that at the time
of recording this
but i hope that the funny way the clever
way and the honest way
to change the topic of conversation were
really useful to you
tons more resources if you want a free
excerpt of the book if you liked these
cards lions and zebras there's links to
them in the description
i exist on the planet to gently
eradicate small talk and create
conversations that matter
which is why i spend a lot of time and
investment
money to create these videos because i
think
that life is too short to chat about
stuff we don't want to chat about
have an awesome
[Music]
day